auf meinen reisen durch deutschland höre
ich seit einiger zeit immer öfter einen
satz
man kann nicht mehr alles sagen zum
beispiel beim thema krone oder bei der
flüchtlingsfrage
ist da was dran wird der meinungs-
korridor enger in den medien im job im
freundeskreis oder ist das quatsch
es geht darum dass eine meinung
vorgegeben ist und wenn man dann wagt
eine kleine kritik zu äußern
dann wird man sofort in grund und boden
gestampft das meinungsklima ist rauer
geworden das sagen viele
aber hat das wirklich was mit
meinungsfreiheit zu tun
wie steht es um die meinungsfreiheit bei
uns das wollte ich von ihnen wissen und
habe über das zdf und die sozialen
medien einen aufruf gestartet
die resonanz war gewaltig 3000
kommentare allein bei facebook
es sind nachrichten aus einer
unversöhnlichen aufgewühlten
gesellschaft wir haben in diesem land zu
100% meinungsfreiheit punkte solange
menschen wegen ihrer meinung öffentlich
diffamiert werden oder ihren job
verlieren
so lange ist meinungsfreiheit ein nettes
märchen
[Musik]
meinungsfreiheit gibt es nur noch in
eine richtung alles andere wird in die
große nazi schublade gepackt erbärmlich
[Musik]
viele verwechseln leider eine meinung
haben mit rassismus intoleranz oder
einfach nur dummheit einige die mir
geschrieben haben habe ich in den
letzten wochen besucht sie haben mir
geschrieben kontroverse meinungen sind
einfach häufig rechts ja glaub du dich
jetzt mit irgendjemandem über migranten
oder sowas unterhält städtische doch mal
hat es erst mal gleich mal direkt nazi
[Musik]
wie steht es um die meinungsfreiheit
ein gymnasiallehrer besucht eine
querdenker demonstration und gibt dabei
dem hessischen rundfunk ein kurzes
interview bin für meine schüler da ich
bin für meine kinder da ich möchte gerne
wieder das wir normales leben haben dass
die angst voreinander nicht irgendwie
alles bestimmt daraufhin bricht ein
twitter shitstorm über ihn herein
tenor querdenker raus aus unseren
schulen die kabarettistin lisa eckert
wird von einem literatur festival
ausgeladen weil sie so der vorwurf auf
der bühne mit antisemitischen klischees
spiele eine berliner u-bahn-station darf
nicht mehr mohrenstraße heißen und an
der frage ob für gender sternchen
verwenden sollen können freundschaften
zerbrechen
was dürfen wir sagen und was nicht wo
liegt die grenze des sagbaren und wer
zieht sie
darüber diskutieren wir als gesellschaft
gerade zunehmend unversöhnlich online
und offline alle gelassenheit alles
wohlwollen ist weg und auch wir medien
sind längst teil dieser aufgeregten
debatte das haben wir einige sehr klar
geschrieben
ausgerechnet das zdf will eine doku über
meinungsfreiheit bringen und dann zeigt
er wieder nur ausgesuchte politisch
korrekte meinungen
ich will aber ja auch genau dorthin wo
es wehtut
wo wir als öffentlich rechtliche medien
nicht mehr gern gesehen sind
das war nicht einfach die meisten die so
denken wollten nicht vor die kamera
in hürth bei köln aber war ich
willkommen von hier bekam ich diese
nachricht
wir leben in einer gesinnungs diktatur
die freie meinung ist seit 2020
endgültig geschichte
[Musik]
hallo
mareike müller hat sie mir geschrieben
sie ist geschieden hat zwei erwachsene
kinder hat geschichte und englisch
studiert und führt eine eigene kleine
marketing-firma sie haben geschrieben
wir würden in einer gesinnungs diktatur
leben ja wie haben sie das gemeint ich
hab das gemeint weil es mir außer die
einigen jahren aufgefallen ist es
irgendwie eine meinung vorgegeben wird
von auch zeitungen oder medien und diese
meinung wir müssen alle folgen und wenn
man dann wagt eine kleine kritik zu
äußern
dann wird man sofort in grund und boden
gestampft aber inwiefern weil gesinnungs
diktatur ist echt ein hartes war ich
sage ich mal ein beispiel wo sie das
gefühl haben da sind sie in ihrer
meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt ich bin
in meiner meinungsfreiheit auf jeden
fall im bereich corona angestrengt also
das ist jetzt ein aktuelles beispiel der
äußere über zum beispiel dass ich mit
einigen regelungen nicht einverstanden
bin muss ich mich sofort erklären und
sagen ja auf keinen fall bin ich eine
koreanerin natürlich muss ich erstmal in
ein vorwort reden bevor ich überhaupt
was kritisieren darf und das empfinde
ich schon als er diktatorisch wenn wir
so eingeschränkt werden aber was genau
dürfen sie nicht sagen ich darf nicht
sagen dass ich die maßnahmen für
überzogen halte ich darf nicht sagen
dass ich an bestimmte zahlen beispiele
nicht glaube nicht dass ich den
instituts wert für falsch berechnet
hatte
das sagen was passiert dann dann werde
ich beschimpft auf facebook oder auch
twitter und dann jedoch auf die
intensivstation oder verrecke doch das
ist natürlich sehr polemisch und und
beleidigen aber das ist hat ja mit
meinungsfreiheit nichts zu tun
ich finde schon früher fühlte sich
mareike müller politisch sehr wohl in
deutschland
sie hat mal ganz euphorisch angela
merkel gewählt eine frau als
bundeskanzlerin
das fand sie toll heute wählen sie sich
in einer meinungs- und gesinnungs
diktatur in ihrer nachricht auf meinen
aufruf hin schrieb sie noch
wenn ich mit menschen sprechen die noch
in der ddr aufgewachsen sind sagen sie
mir auf dass es inzwischen hier
schlimmer ist sich frei zu äußern als
damals in der ddr
mir fällt es schwer das ernst zu nehmen
was sie sagen wenn sie gleichzeitig
behaupten sie würden in einem land leben
wo die meinungsfreiheit so eingeschränkt
sei wie in der ddr
das können sie doch nicht vergleichen
doch das verbindet indem man ins
gefängnis kommt für eine andere meinung
ja was passiert denn heute vielleicht
hier das wird den ball passieren
ich meine wie viele demonstranten was
wird dann passieren dass wir uns
gefängnis kommt ich kann mir das
durchaus vorstellen dass das vielleicht
der weg ist auf denen wir uns zu bewegen
das meinen sie mich jetzt doch das meine
ich ernst was soll denn genauso wie in
der ddr sein
es geht darum dass eine meinung
vorgegeben ist und die scheint
anscheinend unumstößlich zu sein ja und
wer davon abweicht also heute habe ich
noch so ein völlig absurdes beispiel
gelesen hat irgendeine grüne abgeordnete
wurde gefragt was sie denn als kind
gerne gewesen wäre und er hat sie gesagt
sie wäre gerne indianer häuptling
gewesen und sofort ist sie von allen
seiten haben sie vielleicht gehört
angegangen worden
wie könnte man das wort indianer in mund
nehmen ja das ist doch abstrus für mich
darüber kann man ja auch diskutieren
aber wenn sie solche begriffe verwenden
gesinnungs diktatur oder wenn sie sagen
es ist wie in der ddr
ja das ist doch klar dass die gegner und
kriegen und den müssen sie doch dann
auch außerdem halte ich doch auch aus
habe ich überhaupt kein problem mit
ich erwarte doch nicht dass sie diese
begrifflichkeit übernehmen oder haben
sie das gefühl nein aber sie beklagen
dannemann und diktatur
[Musik]
im streit um die meinungsfreiheit haben
kampfbegriffe konjunktur diktatur
gleichschaltung ddr 2.0 viele empört
genau das
[Musik]
wer sich in deutschland ernsthaft in
seiner meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt
fühlt sollte vielleicht mal nach
nordkorea schauen aus wildau eine halbe
autostunde südlich von berlin schrieb
mir karin schubert sie hat in der ddr
gelebt hallo hallo
sind sie ein bisschen aufgeregt ganz
toll wirklich ja auch kein kaffee
getrunken wird auf regelungen genau
karin schubert hatte mir erst abgesagt
sie ist zurückhaltend wollte nicht ins
fernsehen
aber dann hat sie sich doch dazu
entschieden ihre geschichte zu erzählen
wie ihr damals in der ddr verboten wurde
weiter als lehrerin zu arbeiten
herzlichen dank schubert wir haben ja
einen aufruf gestartet zum thema
meinungsfreiheit und extrem viele
nachrichten bekommen und einige haben
sich da auch auf die ddr bezogen
wenn ich meine meinung sagen sollte
würde ich wohl im knast landen fühle
mich in die ddr zurück versetzt
sie haben in der ddr gelebt genau wie
sehen sie das echt ganz gar nicht
verstehen denn ich bin in der ddr groß
geworden aufgewachsen und das ist ist
man kann es überhaupt nicht vergleichen
ich hatte in der ddr sehr viel
schwierigkeiten
ich war dort lehrer und dort musste ich
wirklich und meiner meinung sehr
zurückhaltend das ist eben passiert
das war in berlin in pankow war ich an
der schule und 1979 war der einmarsch
der sowjetischen truppen in afghanistan
und wir sollten eine petition
unterschreiben dass wir uns damit
solidarisch erklären und ich war damals
die einzige die gesagt hat ich muss mich
erst informieren ich unterschreibe das
nicht und spenden auch nicht und das
ging natürlich gar nicht ich wurde dann
zum kreis schulrat zitiert entweder
müsste ich meinen dienst als lehrer
quittieren
oder ich nehme das wieder zurück und ich
war damals in der situation dass ich
zwei schulpflicht die kinder hatte und
bei aller entstehen und das war
eigentlich für mich eine existenzfrage
so dass sich das schriftlich widerrufen
habe um weiter als lehrer arbeiten zu
können
und das war also
für mich war das eine ganz ganz
furchtbar zeit dieses dieses heucheln
müssen
karin schubert wechselte die schule zog
von pankow nach bernau
doch die probleme blieben die gleichen
letztendlich stellte man mich auch
wieder vor die wahl also entweder ende
ich mein verhalten und ich passe mich
mehr an oder man müsste mich aus dem
schuldienst entfernen und um dem
zuvorzukommen habe ich dann letztendlich
selber gekündigt
wie war das für sie dass sie ihren beruf
aufgeben muss gehört es war ganz
furchtbar das war für mich war das eben
ganz ganz schlimm wenn ich meine klasse
tür zugemacht habe ich war mit meinen
kindern alleine war das wunderbar und
war ein schönes arbeiten aber dieses
ganze drumherum dass man dinge tun
musste die man eigentlich gar nicht tun
wollte
das wollte ich nicht noch so viele jahre
eben mitmachen
mit all diesen erfahrungen wie schauen
sie heute auf die diskussion in
deutschland des jahres 2001 und hat um
die meinungsfreiheit sagte ich eben am
anfang schon weil ich das überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen kann ja was ist da
weder ddr organisch also es passiert mir
doch nichts und ich denke mir viele
haben das vergessen oder wollen es oft
vergessen
es geht hier nicht um die plumpe
gegenüberstellung da die böse ddr hier
die gute bundesrepublik ich glaube nur
dass uns solche keulen wie diktatur oder
ddr 2.0 überhaupt nicht weiterbringen
aber auch viele menschen die diese keule
nicht schwimmen finden wir haben in
deutschland ein problem mit dem
meinungsklima zwei drittel aller bürger
geben in umfragen an man müsse heute
aufpassen zu welchem thema man sich wie
äußere auch viele die mir geschrieben
haben beklagen man werde viel zu schnell
in eine schublade gesteckt stempel drauf
ende der diskussion
er sagt was er denkt ist doch gleich ein
nazi
wenn man nicht beschimpft in eine ecke
oder schublade gesteckt werden will
hält man als andersdenkender lieber
seine klappe eine lange mail erhielt ich
aus spraitbach einer 3000 seelen
gemeinde in der schwäbischen provinz
[Musik]
armin psk hat sie mir geschrieben hallo
freut mich
armin psk ist 50 jahre alt
vertriebsleiter bei einem mittelständler
dieselfahrer motorradfan
[Musik]
beschaulich spiel sich schön ja gut
bürgerlich wie es so schön heißt
mit seiner frau und seinem vater bewohnt
er hier sein elternhaus weit ab vom
trubel der großstadt
sie haben mir geschrieben
man hat ständig das gefühl oder lebt in
der angst direkt in schubladen gesteckt
zu werden ja was meinen sie damit
er ist eigentlich im prinzip genau der
punkt wenn man darüber spricht oder
regale welches thema es ist durch sofort
in der schublade steckt also klassisches
beispiel ob du dich jetzt mit jemandem
über ja über über migranten oder sowas
unterhält städtische doch bereits jetzt
schon gleich mal direkt nazi was heißt
dass man das gleiche nazi ich glaube
dass für jemand der das einen so
unterstellt glaube ich dass es die
einfachste sache ist sich nicht mit
einer meinung auseinanderzusetzen und
jemanden am schnellster mundtot zu
machen ist und genau diese schublade ein
zutage
und ich glaube dass das schon dran
vielen hindert das sie dann überhaupt
erstmal in die diskussion gehen weil das
wiki keiner will irgendwo in der
schublade gesteckt weil wir einfach gar
nicht passt oder nicht drin selbst also
es kommt so eine keule meinen sie das
kommt die keule keine ahnung auch das
jetzt bitten mit den querdenkern da
hörst du auch nur noch dass sie dann
unterwandert werden von nazis ich weiß
anne das ist immer bei uns so ganz
schnell benutzt das wort
wo vielleicht klar du wirst du triffst
dann mit sicherheit irgendwann
prozentpunkt triffst du wichtig aber ich
glaube dass ein großteil der überhaupt
nix am hut hat diese schublade auf und
dann erst mal ein riesen stempel den
eigentlich keiner will abzukriegen
ich denke dass das echte großes problem
ist sind sie schon nazi genannt worden
also ich persönlich nicht
das was mir armin psk schildert haben
mir viele geschrieben dass die angst vor
dem nazi stempel hätten angst in die
rechte ecke gestellt zu werden
wenn man dann aber fragt ob ihnen das
schon passiert sei antworten fast alle
nein mir persönlich noch nicht
es scheint also eher ein gefühl zu sein
woher kommt dieses gefühl
man hat das gefühl man kann nicht mehr
alles sagen bei ihnen angefangen
also ich würde jetzt sagen das ist
sicherlich schon tatsächlich so um die
2015 losgehen mit dem ganzen wurde
eingemeindungen extrem auseinander
gegangen sind ich fick sage ich ich ich
habe es auch in ordnung führender wenn
man wenn man leute aufnimmt aber man
kann jetzt sagen ohne ende und man kann
auch sagen es gibt keinen plan b nur hin
zu gehen und sagen wir schaffen das ist
das war meiner meinung nach völlig
falsch und sie findet man konnte nicht
sachlich darüber diskutieren es geht na
das geht ja heute aber kaum also kann
sich heute kaum noch sachlich darüber
spreche eigentlich finde ich
armin psk hat noch ein zweites ich er
ist rocker seit 30 jahren mitglied bei
den black devils wenn er mit ihnen
unterwegs ist sagt er könne er noch
immer frei reden ohne angst in eine
schublade gesteckt zu werden
[Musik]
ich bin leidenschaftlicher
motorradfahrer und und lebt dass auch
ich lebe das also mit haut und haaren
unserer szene da kann viel offener mit
miteinander umgehen und auch mit themen
sprechen weil die menschen dort so
denken wie sie oder weil es eine andere
diskussionskultur geht es ist andere
diskussionskultur jeder kann mit seiner
ideen mit seinem vogel mit seiner
meinung dafür jederzeit kommen also das
ist ja lästigen jahren machen egal
ok und solange du mir aber nicht deine
meinung aufzwingen ist es auch völlig in
ordnung also das ist dieses aufzuhängen
der einigen meinung da denke ich hat die
meinungsfreiheit schon vielleicht auf
dass das genau das richtige ist ist du
musst das jetzt tun das finde ich
schlecht was möchte ich nicht
[Musik]
ich bin nicht sehr gut mensch ich bin
mit allen ecken und kanten ganz stinker
maler der auch mal wie es zeigt der fall
sein kann
auf gut schwäbisch gesagt weil es ja der
einfach nur nett sein kann der alfa
haben wir anders sein kann
ich glaube ja wenn armin theis gesagt er
könne seine meinung nicht mehr frei
äußern geht es ihm eigentlich vor allem
um respekt respekt vor einem wie er
selbst sagt spießigen leben das nicht in
allem dem zeitgeist aus den großstädten
entspricht das nicht in allem eine
moralische verfehlung sieht dem fleisch
auf dem grill dem diesel vor der tür der
röhrenden halle er will sich nicht
vorhalten lassen dass er ein falsches
leben führe und die anderen das richtige
wie steht es um die meinungsfreiheit bei
uns das wollte ich wissen und habe
deshalb über das zdf und die sozialen
medien einen aufruf gestartet
viele die mir geschrieben haben halten
das für eine geisterdebatte jeder in
deutschland kann sagen was er sie es
will nazis kriegen natürlich unter
umständen probleme alle anderen alles im
lot
er füttert gerade die trolle mehr unsinn
redet muss mit gegenrede rechnen
das können viele nicht mirjam marx hat
mich zu sich nach berlin eingeladen
das ist also die eher fernsehshow vor
allem bei
[Musik]
sie ist 22 studiert psychologie im
fünften semester
sie schrieb mir
finde es schon spannend wie einige gegen
minderheiten hetzen und sobald man ihnen
widerspricht gleich meinungsfreiheit
brüllen und sich als opfer darstellen
wie steht's um die meinungsfreiheit bei
uns gut würde ich sagen also ich sehe
nicht wirklich dass wir in deutschland
ein problem mit meinungsfreiheit haben
warum haben dann so viele menschen das
gefühl dass man eben nicht mehr alles
sagen kann weil sie verwechseln das wenn
ihre meinung kritisiert wird dass sie
die nicht mehr sagen dürfen aber zu
meinungsfreiheit gehört ja nicht dazu
dass jeder person sagen kann was sie
möchte und das im leeren raum steht
sondern wenn ich etwas als was ich nicht
sexistisch zum beispiel befinde dann
sage ich das auch weiß nicht betrifft
als frau und genauso sprechen ja immer
mehr menschen viel lauter auch rassismus
an
wir haben geschrieben kontroverse
meinungen sind einfach häufig rechts
sind sie auch oft also ich kann
natürlich auch nur aus dem erzählen was
ich wahrnehme
aber wenn irgend ein kommentar ist zu
weiß ich beispiel vergewaltigung
statistik in deutschland oder das fragen
sich auf deutschen straßen unsicher
fühlen dann kommt 100 prozent in der
kommentarspalte irgendein typ der sagt
oh ja das ist erst 2015 so als auch das
ist nur wegen den geflüchteten menschen
so das ist mir tut der sich 100 prozent
nicht für frauenrechte einsetzt sich
nicht dafür interessiert was irgendwie
wie frauen sich fühlen oder wenn sie
sich unsicher fühlen was kann ich machen
dass frauen sich auf den straßen sicher
fühlen sondern einfach nur das thema
nimmt um irgendwie den rassistischen
quatsch denn da irgendwie kommentare zu
schreiben und so hält interessierst du
dich sonst auch für frauenrechte oder
beschäftigst du nicht nur damit weit
jetzt gerade irgendwie
seine ideologie passt das ist ja ein
gutes beispiel also das beispiel was sie
schildern da ist der kommentar natürlich
absurd aber es ist ja schon die frage ob
man jetzt in deutschland beispielsweise
kriminalität von geflüchteten jetzt nur
als ein beispiel ob man das sachlich
diskutieren kann oder ob dann auch immer
gleich irgendjemand um die ecke kommt
und sagt das ist
ich glaube das ist ein thema was wird
schwierig ist es sachlich zu diskutieren
was halt daran die
dass es ja auch oft missbraucht wird
ein grund seien gar nicht mehr als
gesellschaft können also ich bin viel in
sozialen netzwerken unterwegs den
kommentarspalten und kriegt da auch
wahnsinnig viel emotionen entgegen und
werfe könne nicht genau zu sagen aber
ich habe keine meinungsfreiheit weil die
leute ja dann auch das kritisieren was
ich schreibe was ja völlig okay ist es
ist ja nicht eine einseitige sache dass
sozusagen aus dem linken spektrum rechte
meinungen kritisiert werden und den
leuten nicht zugehört wird sondern
umgekehrt ist das ja auch unbedingt
vorhanden ob das jetzt zielführend ist
oder nicht ist eine andere frage aber
ich finde dort sind weiterhin wichtig
dass auch ja eindeutig kritisiert und
wenn leute sechs ist nun oder rassismen
widersprach reproduzieren weil das
wahnsinnig problematisch muss mir ja
marx benutzt das gender sternchen sie
sagt bürger innen nicht bürger
sie sagt n wort würde nie rassistische
begriffe auch nur aussprechen
sie will so auf ungerechtigkeiten
aufmerksam machen haltung zeigen
doch nicht wenige fühlen sich genau
dadurch moralisch bevormundet das wird
man doch wohl noch sagen dürfen brüllen
die einen die vielzitierten alten weißen
männer privilegierter rassist schreien
die anderen die so genannten open die
aufgeklärten zurück wie kommt man hinter
diesem blatt polemischen gegensatz wie
können wir uns darüber verständigen wie
und wann sprache verletzt
wie sich die grenze was man sagen darf
auch mit der zeit verschiebt ich treffe
moses p
er ist in berlin aufgewachsen profi
basketballer im letzten sommer hatte
eine petition gestartet
er fordert die umbenennung der berliner
u-bahn-stationen onkel toms hütte
er schreibt der begriff onkeltom ist in
der afroamerikanischen und black
community höchst beleidigend warum ist
das so weil das buch von harriet beecher
stowe onkel toms hütte ist ja eigentlich
gegen sklaverei gerichtet das stimmt
aber onkeltom wahrheit in dem buch ein
sklave der sehr unter wirklich war immer
die andere wange hingehalten hat wenn
man als onkel tom bezeichnet wird es
eigentlich dieses eine der schlimmsten
bezeichnung und kleinen schwarzen
menschen
sie argumentieren ja mit einem gefühl
nämlich dass sie so ein name verletzt
wie kann man darüber in der debatte
führen also was kann man so einem gefühl
entgegensetzen ohne sie beispielsweise
zu verletzen in so einer diskussion man
sollte meinen gefühl anerkennen das ist
sehr wichtig in dieser rassismus debatte
auf jeden fall ist sehr sehr wichtig
im letzten jahr wurde in berlin nach
langem streit die mohrenstraße in
glinker straße umbenannt
mehr als 13.000 menschen haben
inzwischen die petition von moses peking
unterschrieben nicht nur die u bahn
station heißt onkel toms hütte sondern
auch eine straße und ein angrenzendes
viertel für die menschen hier ist es
also ein stück identität
ich finde das total berechtigt
ich persönlich verbinde mit dem verein
sehr positives nur weil ich ja teilweise
aufgewachsen kindheitserinnerung aber
wenn er sich zum hintergrund ist das was
ganz anderes
50 jahren hier und kenne das nicht das
ist zur tradition und keine schlechte
tradition und hat keinen magna aus
meiner sicht deswegen zu bliebe nicht
vorschlagen einfach den onkel weglassen
tomtom in den kommentarspalten im netz
verläuft die diskussion darüber bei
weitem nicht so entspannt
solche aktionen tun einfach nur wert auf
rassismus zu sehen wo keiner ist ganz
deutschland wird mal umbenannt
nur noch traurig hier der kampf gegen
den rassismus ist ja super wichtig nur
was genau bringt es für diesen kampf
jetzt so einen namen zu ändern
ja es war eine diskussion an menschen
wären gezwungen darüber nachzudenken wie
menschen sich fühlen mit migrations
blocken oder die etwas anders aussehen
oder eine andere sexuelle orientierung
haben geht es ihnen denn um wirklich um
einzelne formulierungen oder ist es eher
so eine art symbol auch für sie es ist
eine art symbol es geht mehr um die
frage von respekt im alltag werde ich
von jedem in deutschland respektiert
basierend auf wer ich bin und nicht wie
ich aussehe oder was seine sexuelle
orientierung ich habe da sind wir noch
nicht werde immer noch ich hatte immer
noch anders behandelt wenn dieser
respekt da sein wird da müssen wir nicht
mehr über einzelne stationen einzelne
straßen sprechen müssen wir über
bezeichnungen reden weil es kein grund
dafür gibt verstehen sie dass manche
menschen die jetzt vielleicht der
meinung sind dass onkel toms hütte
bleiben sollte dass die angst haben sich
da in so eine diskussion rhein zu
begeben
aus sorge man würde sie als rassist
dahin stellen die 100% 100 prozent und
menschen werden in eine in die rechte
richtung gedrängt die vielleicht gar
nicht mal so rechts seiten sind leute
die
vielleicht nicht immer politisch korrekt
sein wollen haben auf einmal das gefühl
von ausgrenzung und das führt zu diesem
angst zu dieser angst gesellschaft dass
ich nicht mehr sagen kann was ich sagen
will was uns dagegen machen man muss den
das gefühl geben auch einfach dass ihre
meinung nicht direkt über einen kamm
geschoren wird sondern dass wir sie auch
als individuen betrachtet
wie steht es nun also um die
meinungsfreiheit bei uns was mir auf
meiner reise immer klarer geworden ist
in dieser debatte geht es vor allem auch
um die art wie wir miteinander reden um
respekt um augenhöhe um wohlwollen wir
führen polarisierte diskussionen
sortieren und weltanschauliche lager ein
wer anderer meinung ist ist nicht
einfach andere meinungen sondern viel zu
oft ein gegner die sozialen medien
verstärken das extrem meinungsfreiheit
ist für diese debatte eigentlich das
falsche wort
es geht vielmehr um meinungs- toleranz
und auch wenn es wie das wort zum
sonntag klingt wir müssen lernen andere
meinungen besser auszuhalten widerspruch
inklusive